what do you think is the most important  question that humans can ask are we  alone that to me is the most important  question if we're not alone  then somebody else might have answers  to other let's say less  or more immediate existential  uh questions right that you know what  what can we do about this what can we do  about that or  you know are there other dimensions you  could list a thousand questions and you  know if they would be willing to give us  the answers i mean i said this before i  think we're just a bunch of angry angry  apes i don't think we're ready  for uh some of the answers yet and you  know it's like you don't tell your  children certain things until they're  mature enough  and we've pretty much proven that we're  still not mature enough yet